uh as most of you know i want to be
careful it's a very serious subject i
mean it is it is horrifying
watching what happened in waukesha if
you haven't heard a man took an suv and
he plowed into people just running them
over there's several casualties
dozens of injuries there is a very
horrifying video where a little girl is
just bouncing a little toddler bouncing
in the street and the car passes within
you know maybe a foot or two of this kid
and i'm just thinking the parents must
have been crying seeing what happened
and knowing how close their child came
is this is horrifying and we want to
know what the motive is we don't
necessarily know everybody's speculating
and it's hard to say for sure but this
guy
has a criminal record involving kids or
a child so that's very serious
but he's also a
black lives matter supporter
he supported black nationalism he's been
critical of trump
and there's been a lot of speculation so
here's the story from from the examiner
black lives matter activist wonders
whether waukesha attack was linked to
written house verdict sounds possible
the revolution has started now
i'll throw i'll call out the examiner a
little bit here his his exact quote is a
little bit different from sounds
possible
and then they stop the then quote
revolution started he says
i i believe his exact quote is
it but it sounds possible that that the
revolution okay to be fair they're only
taking out a couple words he says but it
sounds possible that the revolution has
started in wisconsin it started with
this christmas parade this is a guy
named vaughn l maze now i don't think
it's fair to say this guy is calling for
it agreeing with it or otherwise but i
think it's important to note that this
guy not like he's a powerful influencer
that's his frame of mind that he sees
this and his immediate reaction was
retaliation over the written house
verdict many people on the right have
pointed out the same thing it is it is
two days not not even two days not even
two full full days from the written
house verdict when already tons of
leftists were saying
i'll be careful about high phrase but
threatening death
on many people not just kyle you have
people going on twitter saying
retaliation revenge something like this
happens from a guy who's been promoting
the stuff on his social media that's
what it seems like now i want to stress
the police have said there's no they do
not believe it's terror at this point
they're saying he was not being pursued
he was fleeing some crime which i think
makes no sense we have this from andy
noe
he supported blm causes george floyd
black nationalism
and he has a post about how to run away
about running running people over on the
street and getting away with it
so
that being said
the big takeaway is not what his true
motive was and i say this often when it
comes to this stuff it's how people
react if the left and the right are both
reacting that this is political it
becomes political yeah i think uh not
just how they react i i agree with you
on that um how people react it becomes
political it gives us a pulse check on
the country and where we are we've been
hearing this sort of rhetoric kind of
bubbling beneath the surface in you know
internet forums and stuff over the past
couple years but it's becoming more and
more of a mainstream idea oh sorry i'll
get on the mic
but the
the other aspect of this is the media's
culpability because the media has been
misrepresenting the kyle rittenhouse
case
for the past year and they've been
misrepresenting the case after the
verdict after the facts have come out
over and over again if you if you
watched our show we had the entire trial
streaming and you could see the actual
facts coming out in real time from the
witnesses who were there the media has
completely whitewashed over those facts
being put out there the only place
that's done anything to even mildly walk
it back is cnn saying oh we now found
out that the gun didn't cross state
lines that that clip was amazing i don't
know if you guys have seen it but uh uh
they're like we've learned some things
in the trial and then they just rattle
off this huge list of everything they
they glossed over and got wrong that
we've all known since the beginning and
then when cernovich was like they're
basically they're scared of getting sued
the reporter responded with sir i am
just a reporter no one's making me say
this and i'm like bull crap yeah they're
just running cover for the covington uh
so they don't have a repeat of the
covington trial but again i would go
even further i would say that the the
corporate media because that's what they
are they have been race baiting hustlers
for the past two years
on an insane level pushing a divide and
conquered yeah i was gonna say far
longer far longer than two but but ever
since occupy wall street i would say
became more prominent but the last two
years has kind of crescendo in this
moment of insanity that really has real
life effects we saw the mainstream media
purport things that actually resulted in
people getting hurt injured or killed in
many instances social media of course
promoted that but look at look at what
cnn look at their headline today their
headline today was that
it was quote there's nothing more
frightening than an angry white man this
is after the tragedy day after yes hours
after
five people died 48 people were injured
and this kind of thinking it's it's not
just an exception to the role it is the
role for the corporate media this guy
he's speaking because he probably
watches a lot of corporate media there
was another illinois democrat that
almost said the same exact thing mary
lamonsky who said that this was karma
and that this was
an act of self-defense
because kyle rittenhouse was acquitted
so these are mainline white women
karen's even talking about the same
points as this blm guy that you just
played that that just released that
video now how the police gonna come out
and say yeah the guy is political yeah
all these political people are
celebrating it but it's not terror
well look he's not wearing a turban i
mean to be fair yeah is that
but the left would immediately be like
that's not terrible i like the subjects
of today's conversation one karma i'm
like the resident indian so i'm
definitely able to talk about that
two we're talking about defamation and
we're going full turbine so i'm like i'm
ready
awesome but no i don't know if you know
this but that's why i started
fightwithcash.com it's literally i'm
suing new york times political and cnn
for 150 million for defamation because
of my work during russia gate and trump
administration they've literally defamed
me across the board and then when i left
government earlier this year people were
like i want to sue for defamation i
don't know how to do that so literally
the entire legal trust is i don't make a
dime we cut checks to lawyers who are
willing to take on defamation cases
across the country and that's what we're
doing and i'm glad you guys are fighting
the fight and if you need well let us
know i got good news for you i uh i
think at this point
you could just be a defamation lawyer
and probably be rich for the rest of
your life just you you never run out of
work it's not hard work i mean you know
normally i remember going back a few
years and it's like defamation and
stuff and it's like well how do you
prove damages and how do you prove this
and how do you prove that and these days
it's like just give cnn five minutes to
report on the story yeah and then you
can sue them and it's clear
actionable they're they're they're it's
easy to prove that they were wrong they
knew they were wrong and you just make
some money you know we'll call it sand
manning yeah well we have we have a
bunch of people doing that work right
sandman paved the way for going after
journalists project veritas has been
making huge headway um winning winning a
lot of pre-trial motions in new york
that people didn't think they could win
new york reinforced its anti-slap
statute made it a lot stronger and they
went ahead and steamrolled right over it
in their case against uh
against new york times and and so the
biggest bar to a defamation lawsuit has
been um can i afford the lawyer to do it
because lawyers you know unless it's a
really clear case and a really clear
case of defamation is extremely rare
you're not going to find a lawyer taking
it on contingency they got to put in the
hours if you're going after someone like
cnn the amount of resources that have to
be expended to fight those guys is
massive so you you can't just assume
that you're going to win and be able to
recover i want to talk about a lot of
that in greater depth because we do have
a story there's civil lawsuits filed in
the rittenhouse case so we'll we'll get
much more in depth on this but i want to
shift it back to
you know this tension that's rising
between the left and the right following
this what scares me is that for the
longest time
we have seen instances of some kind of
violence and immediately i mean let's be
honest the establishment the corporate
press is much more likely to do this
than the right is to the right's
disadvantage
the cal written house is a perfect
example he he crossed state lines with a
gun he shot black people like none of
which is true but they just keep saying
it over and over again then when it
comes to you know other instances you'll
get the right or i should not even
necessarily the right but the the
anti-establishment the the you know the
establishment critical whatever saying
you know this might not be political
this might be random and we'll try to
make sure we're getting the facts
correct now i'm seeing a lot of people
say no revenge
now that now i'm seeing all these tweets
from conservatives saying i don't care
why the guy did it if he has any posts
that are pro black lives matter this was
a black lives matter attack if if we
escalate to that point and i think
the the establishment's driving it okay
this is going to contribute to more
chaos more clashes and it actually will
invoke more attacks and just make
everything worse yeah i mean there's a
lot of details here that we should talk
about but we should talk about it in an
honest perspective because there are
some people arguing that he was
deliberately turning into people when he
was driving he wasn't being chased he
called for political violence on white
people before he did refer to white
people as quote the enemy he was a huge
colin kaepernick fan there's a lot of
that last one that's it yeah
that's that's the thing i've heard is it
all colin kaepernick's fault of course
not no now but but some of these details
do matter and they do deserve to be
talked about in an honest real way where
it's not just pointing at people but but
he was an extreme criminal he had
he had an extensive criminal past he was
just released two days ago on a thousand
dollar bond which the milwaukee
county d.a was bragging about his bail
reform now of course he just came up
publicly and he admitted what he did was
a mistake bailing him out his his record
is is huge why was this man walk in the
streets with such a crazy extensive
record
i'm even saying that as none of a fan
not a fan of the the prison-industrial
complex but but there's something that
needs to be discussed here that
obviously the corporate media is not
willing to discuss doesn't want to
discuss that highlights a lot of
nastiness within our society that does
deserve to be surfaced in my opinion
don't forget that one of the things that
he was being charged with was skipping
bail like so he actually has a record of
not having not honoring the bail
agreements that he has and so for them
to go ahead and then grant a reduced
bail to an absurd amount a thousand
dollar bail to put it in perspective in
in my tiny town uh my town is uh or the
big town near me is about 20 000 people
and um i had a guy on a
uh it's the lowest level of felony drug
possession charge you can have the like
a class e felony and the bail for this
was possession of a little bit of thc
was um twenty thousand dollars wow wow
and and so this guy just had a little
bit of thc trying to lock him up in
prison he actually didn't have any thc
which was even better but uh but yeah
that was the the justification was it
was uh cbd oil and they said oh there's
probably thc in it wow it was it was
embarrassing but the bail on that was
twenty thousand dollars this guy gets a
thousand dollar bail he's got a rap
sheet that uh is significant with
felonies on it there's 25 mug shots in
multiple states that's all i have yes
but but twenty thousand dollar bail that
means two grand down right that means
two grand in minnesota in wisconsin they
have uh well two grand down but if you
uh if you
go ahead and honor the bail agreement
you don't get any back um because that's
you're paying that fee to a bondsman so
um a bondsman will put up your 20 000 in
exchange for 10 percent i see in
wisconsin they don't allow that in
wisconsin it's cash bail uh they don't
allow you to full
full amount so that's why kyle had to
pay the two million dollars uh on his
bail in illinois isn't it like you pay
up 10 you put up 10 or something yeah
some states have that built in other
states use bail bondsmen to do it
wisconsin it's the full cash amount so
his would be the equivalent still of a
ten thousand dollar bail in minnesota
but that's that's nothing i mean and
right
it's absolutely embarrassing with this
guy with several felonies and skipping
bail on his record that that so like
this case highlights like people who
actually want to do criminal justice
reform
and bail reform and bond reform look
i've agreed a thousand bail hearings
okay on the defense and prosecution side
right and there's some nasty guys that
get let out and then there's some really
rich guys who shouldn't get out but get
out because they got a lot of money
right and this kind of conversation
we're having actually goes back to that
which is where the conversation should
be but when cnn and everybody else jumps
in and starts talking about race and
hurling fake news and making up facts
that don't exist then we overlook the
biggest problem yeah i don't think
there's like a normal human being on
planet earth that thinks this guy should
have been out on bail 21 years as a
convicted felon running around town
skipping bail convicted of serious
aggravated felonies and oh by the way
what was he on bail for previously
punching the mother of his child and
running her over twice
allegedly yep right so okay is that not
a violent crime
um maybe and what's he doing on bail you
have this defund police movement that
comes in and it just sort of it's an
avalanche and what these prosecutors now
do is they just curtail themselves to
the whims of the media and they're like
well this is this is the right thing to
do we should just give everybody bail
and i was like i never heard that when i
was a public defender thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you